>> WHAT A BAD WEEK FOR THE
ACTIVIST PRESS.
LAURA LOGAN EVERYBODY IS
PULLING OUT THEIR HAIR.
[LAUGHTER]
$250MILLION THAT'S A LOT OF
MONEY.
THE PAPER MAKES $100 MILLION
OFF OF DIGITAL AD SALES ALONE
THAT'S A LOT OF MONEY THAT IS
MORE THAN I MAKE IT A YEAR.
[LAUGHTER]
HOW DO THEY MAKE ALL THAT
MANY?
THAT BRINGS EYEBALLS THAT
MAKES MONEY SO GET YOUR PIECE
YOU EARNED IT WITHOUT YOU HOW
WOULD CUOMO AFFORD THE DAILY
WAXING?
AT LEAST DAILY AND NOW WITH
THE MEDIA READY CONFLICT WITH
THE TORNADOES AT THE NORMAL
SUSPECT ALL WHITE BRAT IN A
RED HAT SADLY IT TURNS OUT HIS
WHITE RACIST WERE NIGERIAN
BODYBUILDERS - - BODYBUILDERS.
THEIR ABS HAVE ABS.
[LAUGHTER]
THEY HAVE MORE MUSCLES THAN A
MOLLUSK CONVENTION.
IF I HAD ACCESS TO THOSE
WASHBOARD THAT WOULD BE DOING
LAUNDRY EVERY NIGHT OF THE
WEEK.
[LAUGHTER]
SMOLLET PAID THEM 3500 BUT HE
MAKES $60000 PER SHOW SO HE IS
JUST CHEAP.
[BLEEP]
NOW THESE CASES WITH THE
KAVANAUGH SMEAR CALLED
JOURNALISTIC ETHICS.
INTERSECTIONAL STUDIES.
.
>> THE MEDIA EVERYWHERE IS
LIBERAL 85 PERCENT ARE
REGISTERED TO DEMOCRATS.
MOST ARE LEFT OF LIBERAL
DEMOCRAT.
THEN DISAPPEARS FASTER THAN
TAYLOR SWIFT'S BOYFRIENDS.
DON'T EXPECT THE EMPEROR TO
TELL YOU ABOUT IT.
THE FOX IS KNOWN FOR EATING
PEOPLES LUNCHES.
>> SEAN HANNITY AND WILL EAT
SMOLLET LUNCH EVERY SINGLE
SECOND HE WILL EAT SMOLLET
LUNCH EVERY SINGLE SECOND
SPIRIT THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES LEAD HIS LUNCH.
>> I'M GETTING HUNGRY.
AND THEN SO SMOLLET SAW THE
MEDIA FOR WHAT IT WAS, SUCKERS
AND I KIND OF ADMIRE IT BUT IF
YOU'RE ONLY MAD HE WAS USED BY
US AS FODDER WHILE MISSING THE
FACT HE MADE YOU LOOK LIKE A
DUMB ASS THEN YOU TRULY ARE A
LEMON.
[LAUGHTER]
THESE MOMENTS HAVE BEEN PILING
UP AND THEY WERE DRIVEN BY THE
AGENDA AND THE PROFIT MAKER IS
ALWAYS CONFLICT.
>> EVEN THOSE HOMOPHOBIC SLURS
YOU KNOW,  HOW SERIOUS THIS
CRIME IS RIGHT NOW.
>> IN REAL LIFE SMOLLET IS
BLACK AND GAY WHICH COULD BE A
MOTIVATION FOR THE HATE CRIME
SPIRIT JUST AS PEOPLE WHO WEAR
HATS THAT SAY MAG A I DON'T
THINK IT IS PUT OUT THERE THAT
THIS IS A POSSIBLE HATE CRIME.
>> THIS IS AMERICA 2019.
>> CELEBS PLACED THE BLAME
WHERE IT BELONGS ON MIKE PENCE.
>> IT'S NOT IMPOSSIBLE WITH
THE PRESIDENT OR VICE
PRESIDENT.
THIS IS WHAT HAPPENS IF YOU
ARE IN A POSITION OF POWER AND
YOU HATE PEOPLE AND YOU WANT
TO CAUSE SUFFERING TO
THEM, YOU GO TO THE TROUBLE
AND SPEND YOUR CAREER TRYING
TO CAUSE SUFFERING
TO CAUSE  SFFERING
TO CAUSE  SUFERING
TO CAUSE  SUFFEING
TO CAUSE  SUFFERIG
TO CAUSE  SUFFERING.
>> I TRIED TO SIT THROUGH HER
LAST MOVIE SHE SHOULD KNOW
THAT IS SUFFERING.
AND THEN I WONDER HOW THEY
WILL DISCUSS HOW PENCE DID NOT
CREATE A CRIME THAT DID NOT
EXIST.
HERE WE HELD OUR TONGUES EVEN
THOUGH IT STINK LIKE A
BATHROOM AFTER CURRY NIGHT AT
THE REST HOME FF THAT TRUMPS
SUPPORTERS STOCKING THE
CHICAGO STREETS AT 2:00 A.M.
CARRYING A NEWS GOING AFTER AN
ACTOR ON A SHOW THEY DON'T
WATCH AND RECOGNIZE HIM?
AND THE SAME AS ME AS A
BABYSITTER.
THE SANDWICH BREXIT WAS A
SUBWAY.
MAYBE THAT'S THE NEXT GIG.
WHO WRITES CHECKS TO
NIGERIANS?
MAYBE YOUR AUNT ON YOUR
BIRTHDAY.
AND THEN THE MEDIA THAT WANTED
IT SO BADLY TO BE TRUE.
WIRE THE SO COMMON?
ALL OF THOSE THAT HAVE CAUSE
AND EFFECT ARE NOW EMPLOYED IN
THE MEDIA THE VIRUS MAKES YOU
STUPID DID I SAY STUPID?
YES I DID.
SOME PEOPLE WERE SAD I AM
ALWAYS THRILLED WHEN A HATE
CRIME TURNED OUT TO BE FALSE
SO THAT MEANS I'M THRILLED A
LOT.
WHERE HATE CRIMES HAVE TO BE
MADE UP BECAUSE THE DEMAND
EXCEEDS THE SUPPLY.
BUT IF YOU ARE STILL SAD
BECAUSE IT IS YOUR BIAS SETS
YOU UP AS A WILLING STOOGE.
MEDIA OWNS A STORY.
ATTENTION PROFESSIONALS ARE
YOU HUNGRY FOR THE PROFITS AND
GO TO THE SEMINAR.
>> I WILL SHOW YOU SOME
HEADLINES YOU CAN TELL ME HOW
YOU WILL REWRITE THEM FOR
MAXIMUM PROFIT.
OKAY?
HERE'S THE FIRST ONE.
THE STORM TO BLANKET.
>> MIDWEST MAN WINS MEGA
MILLIONS JACKPOT.
>>.
>> YOU ARE A NATURAL.
AND THEN TO CELEBRATE THE 95th
BIRTHDAY?
.
>> THAT REPUBLICAN VOTER TURNS
95.
>> THE CHURCH YOUTH GROUP
HOLDS A BAKE SALE FOR FLOOD
VICTIMS.
>> EXTREMIST VIEW HAVE VICTIMS
OF CARBON TOXIN.
>> YES THE HOUSE FIRE IN
AUSTRALIA INJURED SEVEN.
A VOLCANO INJURED ONLY IN
TRUMPS AMERICA.
>> YOU ALL PASSED WITH FLYING
COLORS I AM SO PROUD OF YOU.
GET OUT THERE AND DO SOME
JOURNALISM.
[APPLAUSE]
.
>> IF YOUR VICTIMS ARE CHRONIC
DOCTOR DREW.
[APPLAUSE]
.
>> HE REALLY GOT BIN LADEN TO
OPEN UP.
AND SHE'S ONLY HAPPY WHEN
SHE'S FEELING CRAPPY.
AND THE LAST TIME THEY HAD TO
CALL THE FIRE DEPARTMENT WHEN
THEY BLEW OUT THE CANDLES.
[APPLAUSE]
DOCTOR DREW YOU ARE A DOCTOR
OR SO YOU SAY HAS AMERICA
TURNED INTO ONE BIG CHURCH OF
VICTIMHOOD QUICK.
>> NOT ONLY THAT WE GIVE SUCH
CREDIBILITY TO BE A VICTIM
THEY WANT TO BE A CERTAIN KIND
OF VICTIM SO BADLY WE ARE
SEEING AN EPIDEMIC WITH THE
SAME CONSTRUCT THAT PEOPLE
WANT TO BE A VICTIM.
GREG: FOR THIS GUY IS BETTER
TO BE A VICTIM THAN TO BE THE
STAR OF A SHOW.
THAT IS INSANE.
>> I'VE BEEN DOING A LOT OF
THINKING.
AND IT'S ALL ABOUT EXACTLY
WHAT HAPPENED.
>> EVEN HE WAS SHOCKED.
.
>> THAT MIGHT BE THE CASE.
>> I AM A STRAIGHT WHITE KID
WHO COULD BE ON THE COVER OF A
MAGAZINE I'VE NEVER BEEN A
VICTIM OF HATE CRIME.
>> BUT ANOTHER TO MAKE IT
HAPPEN.
SO IS THIS MEAL OR MAKING IT
UP?
I DON'T THINK IT'S OVER SALARY
BUT HE HATED TRUMPS SO MUCH TO
MAKE THEM HATE TRUMP MORE.
>> IT MIGHT SOUND RIDICULOUS
BUT
BT
BUT.
>> BUT I WOULD BEAT THEM WITH
THE MEAT.
[LAUGHTER]
THAT CANNOT BE BLEEPED.
THANK YOU.
[LAUGHTER]
I AM BEING APPLAUDED FOR
STRANGE SENTENCE.
[LAUGHTER]
.
>> THIS WHOLE THING CONFUSES
ME.
I LOVE ATTENTION.
I LOVE IT SO MUCH IT PUSHES
PEOPLE AWAY.
[LAUGHTER]
HOWEVER I DON'T THINK RACIST
HOMOPHOBIC ATTACK ON MYSELF
ATTENTION AS HE HEARD ABOUT
POSTING A CELL FEE ON
INSTAGRAM OR STARTING A FIGHT
WITH HIS BOYFRIEND OR
PRETENDING TO BE PREGNANT?
THESE ARE ALL BETTER WAYS LIKE
WRITING TO RIDE A UNICYCLE.
THEY HAVE INVENTED BIKES WITH
TWO WHEELS.
GREG: TRUE.
SEND THE LETTERS TO CAT THAT
YOU ARE DOING IT FOR THE
ATTENTION.
>> ALL FOUR OF THOSE LETTERS.
[LAUGHTER]
WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS?
.
>> YOU SURE GOT REALLY CREEPY
THERE.
[LAUGHTER]
LITERALLY EVERY TIME HE MADE A
GREAT POINT HE SLID IN
SOMETHING CREEPY.
MISSION OR CRY FOR HELP?
.
>> AND WE SHOULD ALL BE
UNIFIED TOGETHER.
AND I WAS TALKING TO DOCTOR
DREW ABOUT THIS AND FIGURING
OUT WHY HE DID THIS WITH THE
SALARY AND WHATEVER I ACTUALLY
MISS THIS BEHAVIOR QUITE OFTEN
IN MY OWN LIFE IN MY OWN HOME.
RUNNING IN THE YARD BACK AND
FORTH AS I HAVE TO DO WORK
MAYBE WATCHING ESPN ON MY
PHONE AND IT SAYS MY LEG.
WHAT HAPPENED?
A SHARK.
[LAUGHTER]
AND THEN LOOK AT ME.
AND A DINOSAUR.
WHAT DO WE DO?
OH MY POOR BABY.
I GIVE HER A HUG.
>> JUST.
[BLEEP]
A HUG.
SHE - - HE SHOULD HAVE PAID
THEM $3500 TO HUG HIM.
[APPLAUSE]
D7 WE HAVE TO ROLL BUT I THINK
IT IS 92 THE DAY THE PEOPLE
ARE COMING FROM THE CAMPUS
DOCTOR DREW AND LIBERTARIAN.
>> WATCH YOUR MOUTH.
>> THEN IF YOU BELIEVE THE
STORY
SORY
STOY
STORY.